the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones in A Song of Ice and Fire
video in today's video I want to talk
about George RR Martin's original
outline for a Song of Ice and Fire
this is something I have made a video
about before because in the outline it
does state which five main characters
would survive the entire story but
that's not what I want to discuss today
in this outline it says a few
interesting things about Jon Snow and
Tyrion Lannister which is what I want to
show you because I have been wondering
if this could still have some sort of
impact on the story or television show
based on one of the recent spoilers that
came out I think there is a very good
chance that it could so let's talk about
what those things are before I get
started I want to make sure I give a
official spoiler warning even though it
has not been confirmed it does come from
a reliable source
so please proceed with caution now I'm
sure most of you are already well aware
of this original outline but there may
be some people watching this video that
have never heard about this until today
in that case I want to make sure all
those people are brought up to speed the
first thing I want to do is read the
letter that George sent to his publisher
that way everyone knows exactly what I'm
talking about
but if you would like to skip over this
portion of the video I will put a
timestamp at the bottom of the screen
some of it is hard to read because there
are some glares in the photos so I'll
just try to summarize what the three
pages said for those of you that don't
know back in 1993 George RR Martin's
sent a three-page letter to his
publisher and in this letter it provided
the basic structure he wanted to have
for his story he originally only wanted
to make it a trilogy but as of right now
he has already published five books and
he has stated he wants to make up the
seven his story has already doubled in
size and once you see what he originally
had in mind for the story you can see he
has already deviated from most of it but
let's take a look at what it says dear
Ralph here are the first 13 chapters 170
pages of the high fantasy novel I
promised you which I'm
calling a game of Thrones when completed
this will be the first volume and what I
see as an epic trilogy with the overall
title a Song of Ice and Fire
as you know I don't outline my novels I
find that if I know exactly where a book
is going I lose all interest in writing
it I do however have some strong notions
as to the overall structure of the story
I'm telling in the eventual fate of many
of the principal characters in the drama
roughly speaking there are three major
conflicts set in motion in the chapters
enclosed these will form the major plot
threads of the trilogy the first threat
grows from the enmity between the Great
Houses a Lannister and stark as it plays
out in a cycle of plot counter plot
ambition murder and revenge with the
Iron Throne of the Seven Kingdoms as of
the ultimate prize this will form the
backbone of the first volume of the
trilogy a game of Thrones while the lion
of Lannister and the dire wolf of Starks
Naro and scrap however a second and
greater threat takes shape across the
Narrow Sea where the Dothraki horselord
smash their barbarian hordes for a great
invasion of the Seven Kingdoms led by
the fierce and beautiful Daenerys
Stormborn the last of the Targaryen
dragons
the Dothraki invasion will be the
central story of my second volume a
dance with dragons the greatest danger
of all however comes from the north from
the icy wastes beyond the wall where
half-forgotten demons at a legend the
inhuman others raise cold legions of the
undead and they're never born and
prepare to ride down on the winds of
winter to extinguish everything that we
would call life the only thing that
stands between the Seven Kingdoms in an
endless night is the wall and a handful
of men in black called the Nights Watch
their story will be the heart of my
third volume the winds of winter the
final battle will also draw together
characters and plot threads left from
the first two books and resolved all in
one big climax the 13 chapters on hand
should give you a notion as to my
narrative strategy all three books will
feature a complex mosaic of intercutting
points of view among various of my large
and diverse cast of players the cast
will not always remain the same old
characters will die and new ones will be
introduced some of the fatalities will
include sympathetic viewpoint characters
I want the reader to feel that no one
has ever completely safe not even the
characters who seem to be the heroes the
suspense always ranches up a notch when
you know that any character can die at
any time five central characters will
make it through all three volumes
however growing from children to adults
and changing the world in themselves in
the process in a sense my trilogy is
almost a generational saga telling the
life stories of these five characters
three men into women the five key
players are Tyrion Lannister Daenerys
Targaryen and three of the children of
Winterfell Arya bran and the bastard Jon
Snow all of them are introduced at some
length and the chapters you have on hand
alright now let me stop right here for a
quick second as of right now everything
in the original outline has pretty much
stayed the same he did not deviate too
far from the backbone of the story the
smaller plot threads is where he started
to make changes but as of right now the
current story has pretty much stayed the
same even those five main characters are
still alive but let's continue this is
going to be I hope quite an epic epic in
its scale epic in its action and epic in
its length
I see all three volumes as big books
running about 700 to 800 manuscript
pages so things are just barely getting
underway in the 13 chapters I've sent
you I have quite a clear notion of how
the story is going to unfold in the
first volume a Game of Thrones
things will get a lot worse for the poor
Starks before they get better
I'm afraid Lord Eddard Stark and his
wife Catelyn Tully are both doomed and
will perish at the hands of their
enemies Ned will discover what happened
to his friend Jon Arryn Joffrey will not
be sympathetic and Ned will be accused
of treason but before he is taken he
will help his wife and his daughter Arya
escape back to Winterfell each of the
contending families will learn it has a
member of dubious loyalty in its midst
Sean's a stark Wed to Joffrey Baratheon
will bear him a son the heir to the
throne and when the crunch comes she
will choose her husband and child over
her parents and siblings a choice she
will later bitterly rue
Tyrion Lannister meanwhile will befriend
both songs and her sister Arya while
growing more and more disenchanted with
his own family he
brain stark will come out of his coma
after a strange prophetic dream only to
discover that he will never walk again
he will turn to magic at first in hope
of restoring his legs but later for its
own sake when his father at art stark is
executed bran will see the shape of doom
descending on all of them but nothing he
can say will stop his brother Rob from
calling the banners and rebellion all of
the north will be inflamed by war Robb
will win several splendid victories in
MAME Joffrey Baratheon on the
battlefield but in the end he will not
be able to stand against Jaime and
Tyrion Lannister and their allies Robb
Stark will die in battle in Tyrion
Lannister will besiege in burn
Winterfell try to remember that little
detail right there it says Tyrion
Lannister will burn Winterfell Jon Snow
the bastard will remain in the far north
he will mature into a ranger of great
daring and ultimately will succeed his
uncle as the commander of the night's
watch when Winterfell burns Catelyn
Stark will be forced to flee north with
her son brain and her daughter Arya
wounded by Lannister Riders they will
seek refuge at the law but the men of
the Nights Watch give up their families
when they take the black and John and
benjin will not be able to help - Jon's
anguish it will lead to a better
estrangement between Jon and bran
area will be more forgiving until she
realizes with terror that she has fallen
in love with Jon who is not only her
half-brother but a man of the Nights
Watch sworn to celibacy their passion
will continue to torment Jon and Arya
throughout the trilogy until the secret
of Jon's true parentage is finally
revealed in the last book abandoned by
the Nights Watch Catelyn and her
children will find their only hope of
safety lies even further north beyond
the wall where they fall into the hands
of Mance Rayder the king-beyond-the-wall
and they will get a dreadful glimpse of
the inhuman others as they attack the
wildling encampment brains magic Arya
sword needle and the savagery of their
dire wolves will help them survive but
their mother Catelyn will die at the
hands of the others over across the
Narrow Sea Daenerys Targaryen will
discover that her new husband the
Dothraki call Drogo has little interest
in invading the Seven Kingdoms much to
her brother
frustration when Viserys presses his
claim past a point of tact or wisdom
called Drago will finally grow annoyed
and kill him out of hand eliminating the
Targaryen Pretender and leaving Daenerys
as the last of her line Daenerys will
bide her time but she will not forget
when the moment is right she will kill
her husband to avenge her brother and
then flee with a trusted friend into the
wilderness beyond vast earth rack then
she begins to play in her invasion of
the Seven Kingdoms
Tyrion Lannister will continue to travel
to plot and to play the game of Thrones
finally removing his nephew Joffrey in
disgust at the boy Kings brutality Jaime
Lannister will follow Joffrey on the
throne of the Seven Kingdoms by the
simple expedient of killing everyone
ahead of him in line of succession and
blaming his brother Tyrion for the
murders exiled Tyrion will change sides
making common cause with the surviving
Starks to bring his brother down and
falling helplessly in love with Arya
Stark while he's at it his passion is
Elias unreciprocated but no less intents
for that and it will lead to a deadly
rivalry between Tyrion and Jon Snow I
hope you will find some editors who are
as excited about all of this as I am
feel free to share this letter with
anyone who wants to know how the story
will go all the best george RR martin
there is one thing i want to say before
we go any further at some point george
RR martin did try to say he was making
things up when he wrote the outline but
i think most of us can agree that's not
entirely true because most of what he
wrote in the outline did end up
happening in the story he may have
deviated from certain aspects of it but
he did not stray too far and for those
of you that did not follow along there
are a few things I want to point out
because it may or may not have an impact
on how the show or story ends in the
original outline is says Tyrion
Lannister and Jon Snow end up in a
deadly love triangle / Arya Stark it
even says Tyrion burns down Winterfell
at one point now I want to talk about
this because there are some spoilers
that have come out that could indicate
something along these lines does happen
the only difference is that may not
involve Arya Stark in the same way that
it says here based on what we've seen in
Game of Thrones
it looks like Jon Snow and Tyrion
Lannister are both in love with Daenerys
Targaryen
we all remember that scene on the boat
when Tyrion had that look on his face as
John and Daenerys went into the cabin to
have sex even the actor Peter Dinklage
who portrays Tyrion Lannister in the
show spoke about this during an
interview with Entertainment Weekly and
it said this speaking to Entertainment
Weekly Dinklage chatted about what he
felt tyrians reaction was after he found
out Jon Snow and Dany started to have
sex the actor said a lot of the time
with Tyrion it's professional and
personal obviously he has feelings for
Daenerys he loves her or thinks he does
she's all inspiring and he's questioning
that because he doesn't have a good
track record for falling in love there's
jealousy wrapped up in there also Annie
loves Jon Snow - they're the two people
he has the most in common with in a way
they're both outsiders and their
families who have refused to follow the
path their family has taken and
hopefully for the better he's wondering
how smart of a move Jon and Danny's
romance is because passion and politics
don't mix well he knows the two of them
getting together could be very dangerous
alright now I wanted to point this out
because it sounds very similar to what
it says in that original outline but
instead of them falling in love with
Arya they fell in love with Daenerys
instead what makes this so interesting
is the fact that it says the love
triangle will turn deadly which means at
least one of these three characters
could end up dead next season now let's
think about some of the recent spoilers
that have came out we know Winterfell
will barn next season based on some of
the photos and videos that were released
online I think most of us including
myself have assumed that this would
happen due to a big battle in the north
as we all know the night king is in the
north heading south in Cersei is in the
south but she could send the golden
company north John and Daenerys could
potentially be stuck in Winterfell as
enemies come from all sides so it's not
too crazy to think Winterfell could get
attacked and possibly burned but what if
Winterfell burns for another reason
what if someone from inside the castle
tries to burn it down for other reasons
in this original outline it says Tyrion
burns down Winterfell so what if that's
why we are actually seeing Winterfell
burn in the photo and videos from the
set now I know some of you may be
thinking why would Tyrion do something
like that
he's trying to help John and Daenerys I
know that's how I always fell but that
was until more details started to come
out the most recent spoiler from freaky
doctor says Tyrion Lannister will die
next season after he is convicted of
treason
apparently they will hold a trial when
the dragon pit in Tyrion will be
sentenced to death this was very hard to
believe at first but the more I think
about it the more I think it might be
true also the actor gave another recent
interview when he said something very
ominous about his characters endgame
during an interview of vulture Dinklage
stated I think Tyrion was given a very
good conclusion no matter what that is
death can be a great way out now as we
all know actors tend to say some
misleading things during interviews but
when you think about some materials last
season along with the possible spoilers
for season 8 maybe Tyrion does actually
die next season maybe he will choose his
family over his friends what if Tyrion
actually betrays Jon and Daenerys next
season and he is the one who burns down
Winterfell just like it said in the
original outline Tyrion and Daenerys did
bump heads during most of the season and
I think we can all agree that Tyrion
made some very stupid decisions that
cost them all greatly then we have the
scene with Tyrion and Cersei that cuts
away before we see how it ends along
with the local Ontarians face when Jon
and Danny go into the cabin alone maybe
Tyrion actually snaps next season and
does the unthinkable the weird thing is
all the characters that would have been
involved with these different plot lines
are a part of the five original main
characters of the story I don't know
about you but Tyrion has always been one
of my favorite characters and he is
actually one of the few characters I
thought were guaranteed to live but now
I'm not so sure
you
when I went back and watched all the
Tyrian scenes in season seven it does
seem like they are foreshadowing Tyrians
betrayal if you go back and watch his
scenes it almost seems obvious now go
back and look at some materials game
planning and look at some of the things
that he said and even all the looks on
his face when certain things were said I
really hate to say it but this might be
the end of the road for our old friend
Tyrion the IMP Lannister what do you
think could there be some truth to the
original outline and all the recent
spoilers or do you think people are just
trying to blow smoke up our asses let me
know if your thoughts have changed on
any of this because I know I constantly
go back and forth with what I believe
when it comes to all the different
so-called spoilers anyways I want to
thank everyone for watching today's
video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for supporting my channel I hope you all
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]